the new Transformers movie Rise of the
beasts has finally arrived bringing in
details from Beast Wars new Transformers
factions and an unexpected crossover
these are all the Easter eggs you may
have missed let them come although
Optimus primal is defined as the leader
of the maximals that wasn't always the
case in the film's opening we see that
there is a leader named ape link who
attempts to keep Scourge distracted
while Primal and others escape this
ultimately causes him to die at
scourge's hand but he's able to pass the
Reigns to Primal before they leave even
though Primal might not have been ready
to fill ape Link's shoes we eventually
watch him become a great leader who has
grown to love humanity and Carries On
the duties of protecting the transwarp
key aside from the opening giving ape
link a different origin it ties to
primal's personal Arc as a leader in his
original Incarnation Primal was
described as a young and inexperienced
Captain who took on leadership duties
that made some question his Readiness
over time he becomes the knowledgeable
and caring leader that impresses Optimus
Prime and plays a pivotal role in battle
a it's great that the film gives more
Credence to Primal start as a young
leader creating a real origin story that
fans will appreciate seeing plus the
film also touches on how primal's
Optimus title is inspired by Optimus
Prime just like it is in his animated
Origins
rise of the beasts isn't the first time
that fans have seen RC on the big screen
she made her live-action debut back in
Revenge of the Fallen and had a brief
cameo in bumblebee during the opening
War sequence on Cybertron however her
appearances have been incredibly brief
and in the case of Revenge of the Fallen
have largely failed to capture the
character's iconic look it's fair to say
that one of Transformers most iconic
female Autobots hasn't exactly been
treated with the respect she deserves
rise of the beasts changes that by not
only giving her more screen time but
also restoring the character to a more
classic look RC's redesign and Rise of
the beasts is heavily inspired by her
look in the 2007 animated series
Transformers Animated although she
trades out bright pink for a reddish
shade she has a Sleek aesthetic that
makes her a terror in battle her look
back in Revenge of the Fallen was just
plain atrocious so it's nice that rise
of the beasts pays tribute to the
character's Legacy by restoring her to
her Superior form
it's established early on that Scourge
has quite a history as a deadly Bounty
Hunter and loves to take trophies as
shown when Scourge kills aplink he loves
to rip off the emblem of his victims and
attach them to himself various symbols
can be seen on his shoulder as well as
behind the grill on the front of his
truck Incarnation well this is a great
nod to scourge's original history as the
leader of a bounty hunter group known as
the sweeps it's also full of fun Easter
eggs along with symbols representing the
Autobots Decepticons and maximals there
are emblems that tie to the autobot
Elite guard and mercenaries however
there's one emblem that'll be much more
familiar to fans eagle-eyed die hards
will notice that a couple of emblems are
connected to the Wreckers who were last
seen in Transformers Dark of the Moon
it's a pretty interesting nod to a fan
favorite faction and an Easter egg that
makes you wonder if the Wreckers will
rise again
for those who don't remember there was a
prequel to rise of the beasts that
focused on bumblebee where he teamed up
with a human protagonist named Charlie
the film set up the Autobots being
stranded on Earth while War continued on
Cybertron although rise of the Beast
isn't technically a direct sequel it
still takes time to acknowledge the
events of the previous film when Optimus
shows some frustration at having to work
with Noah bumblebee openly disagrees
with his view Optimus then acknowledges
that he understands that bumblebee has
worked with humans before but that it
doesn't change how he feels it's a
moment that directly references how
Bumblebee worked with Charlie to protect
Earth as Bumblebee learned in his
titular solo film Optimus follows suit
in his understanding of how important
Humanity can be and Rise of the beasts
eventually developing a real connection
that makes him a protector of Earth
given that bumblebee doesn't directly
tie into what's happening in Rise of the
beasts the latter film didn't need to
reference it for audiences to follow the
threat of the plot but thankfully it
does and Bumblebee fans can feel
acknowledged thank you
with rise of the beasts bringing the
franchise back to the mid 90s it's no
surprise there are plenty of nostalgic
nods to 90s pop culture a lot of the
film's comic book and video game
references come from Noah's brother
Chris when we first see Chris he's
sporting a Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
shirt a show that first premiered in
1993. throughout the film Chris makes
references to different video games
including Super Mario Brothers when he's
talking about being unable to defeat
Bowser and Sonic the Hedgehog when he
wants to use Sonic and Knuckles as code
names over the radio as for music the
film is absolutely littered with
different songs from the 90s two of the
most notable instances are when Elena
sings TLC's Waterfalls to calm herself
down and Bumblebee makes a grand
entrance to the final battle with LL
Cool J's 1990 classic Mama Said Knock
You Out Mirage even brings up how Mark
Wahlberg was in the process of
transitioning from musician to actor
which is even funnier when you realize
that Wahlberg is an Alum of this
franchise having starred in Transformers
Age of Extinction and The Last Knight
something's coming you can't shoot your
way out of it
the fan could ever forget the iconic
Transformers theme that dubs the titular
beings as robots in Disguise and
they are more than and meets the eye
well the latter phrase actually gets a
mention in Rise of the beasts and is
given an interesting new meaning when
talking to optimists about the Peruvian
tribe that has helped to the maximals
during their time on Earth Primal
explains how these people have given him
a new perspective on life and their role
as protectors while Optimus thinks of
humans as weak and a nuisance in his
plans to return home Primal tells him
that he shouldn't doubt them and that
they're truly more than meets the eye
with this pronouncement Primal treats
fans to a new spin on the classic theme
song line and it actually causes
optimus's mindset to change as well from
here he starts to see his purpose on
Earth as something greater and it's what
ultimately makes him a better leader
unlike most Transformers Mirage has a
lot of powers at his disposal he has the
ability to create Holograms of himself
to distract enemies and can even give
Noah his armor to form an exosuit that
helps him fight in battle however one of
mirage's more underrated capabilities is
that he can transform into multiple
types of vehicles from a Sleek Porsche
that can speed through the streets to a
garbage truck that can help in stealth
missions Mirage is basically a Swiss
army knife one vehicle he transforms
into is a nod to his original
Incarnation while showing NOAA the
different cars he can transform into
Mirage turns into a small IndyCar which
is what he has historically been most
identified with in the multiple
different Transformers incarnations it's
a shame that we don't get to see
mirage's IndyCar in action but it's
still a nice callback nevertheless
it's pretty surprising that by this
point Bumblebee's Voice still isn't
fixed and he's the only Transformer who
can't speak however bumblebee being
forced to use his radio frequencies to
communicate has become such a memorable
part of the character that fans
certainly aren't complaining this time
around his lines come from a very
specific Medium as mentioned by Optimus
Bumblebee has been spending a lot of
time at the drive-in so it's not
shocking that a lot of his lines are
from movies he's been watching lately
there are two key instances of Bumblebee
using movies that stand out the most one
heartbreaking and one heroic the
heartbreaking moment comes when
bumblebee sacrifices himself to save
Optimus and he spouts the O Captain my
Captain line from Dead Poet Society
captain my captain sit down Mr Anderson
the other comes with his triumphant
return in the final battle where he puts
his own spin on Roddy Piper's famous
line from John Carpenter's they live I
have come here to chew bubble gum and
kick ass
[Music]
but that bumblebee Loves movies just as
much as we do and frankly he's got good
taste
while Mirage might have sacrificed
himself to save Noah in the film's
climactic battle a mid-credits scene
shows Noah trying to bring back his
friend which leads to a pretty rad
Easter egg with the help of reek Noah is
seen putting Mirage back together in his
car form using scraps that reek brings
him although reek is doubtful of Noah's
plans Mirage eventually Springs back to
life and sports a new color scheme
thanks to all the rust on the scrap
pieces many may not realize it but this
version of Mirage is actually a nod to
another Transformers faction known as
the junkians the junkians are a race and
Transformers lore who reside on the
planet of junk and have a brown colored
aesthetic that's very similar to how
Mirage looks after his reassembly so
mirage's Resurrection comes with a great
little Easter egg for fans that touches
on a faction of junk robots who could
and should make an appearance in a
future film
one of the biggest surprises of Rise of
the beasts was undoubtedly the reveal in
the film's final moments as Noah
continues to look for security work
following his adventure with the
Autobots he comes across a man named
agent Burke who cryptically indicates
that he knows everything that's been
going on he knows all about Noah's time
with the autobots and wants him to join
his secret team in this scene it's tough
to figure out who Burke is or what
organization he works for then as Noah
looks into the secret lab behind the
wall and flips over the card we get the
surprising reveal that Burke is part of
GI Joe now it's not totally out of the
realm of possibility for these two
franchises to have an epic crossover
especially since it's happened before GI
Joe and Transformers have crossed paths
multiple times in the comics and they're
both toy brands under Hasbro plus
Paramount has produced films for both
franchises the GI Joe films haven't
found the same success that Transformers
has at the box office so maybe Paramount
thinks a crossover could benefit both
franchises regardless it's still an epic
Easter egg that teases a potentially
amazing mashup
foreign